hey guys my name is just McDonald it's
the 8th of july today and you have tuned
into games but news first half a couple
of new games have been announced the
first of which is coming from
Borderlands developer gearbox software
the game battleborn is described as a
first-person battle arena it's coming to
xbox one ps4 and PC in 2016 and will be
published by 2k the game is set in the
distant future and will hybridize genres
to bring you FPS gameplay with fancy
stylized visuals you'll get to play an
expensive collection of heroes and as
Randy Pitchford explains if Borderlands
2 is a shirt aluta battleborn is a hero
shooter as a genre fused hobby grade
cooperative and competitive FPS
exploding with eye-popping style and an
imagine with the universe Babel born is
the most ambitious video game that
gearbox has ever created I mean off your
king next up we've been told what clip
was in skis new game is going to be and
guess what it's also an arena shooter
it's called Project Blue Streak and will
be a free-to-play sci-fi arena shooter
for PC it's been created by blue since
keys new studio boss ki productions who
are working with South Korean outfit
nexon known for free to play games like
maplestory next one also own a minority
stake in blue key as a result of the
partnership and blues in ski thinks
they're the right people to help drive
his free-to-play train sony has found a
way to make talking about the weather
exciting again and is by showing off
just how good sad weather looks in
upcoming ps4 game driveclub the game
already charmed us with the sweet
trailer at e3 last month but Sony's
Instagram videos highlighting the
weather system in the racer have already
been pinching the deal for some of you
unfortunately the pretty weather effects
won't be available at launch in October
but Sonia promising the land of the free
update shortly after the games released
evolution studios art director Alex
Perkins has said they want to make the
web system as fun and immersive as
possible everything including
temperature Sun height cloud cover and
wings be
we'll be able to be manipulated to your
whims so you can play God basically in a
driving game also obviously the weather
system isn't just for looks and will
impact on your handling lastly a GDC
europe study has been conducted and it's
unveiled some fairly interesting trends
it was discovered that european devs are
moving over to current gen consoles and
pc although they do seem to be favoring
the ps4 over the Xbox one thirty-three
percent of dev said they were planning
developments for Sony's console while
the Xbox one grabbed two twenty-three
percent of the vote also fifty-eight
percent of European devs are currently
working on pc titles while 65 developing
for mobile interestingly crowdfunding
has also totally blown up with forty-one
percent of the european devs intending
on using the money raising tool for
future games and your question for today
let me know down in that comment section
whether you think game devs should be
using crowdfunding or not those are all
the things i want to tell you about
today be sure to leave me all your
thoughts and feelings and i'll see you
same time tomorrow